when you were teaching students is there
one aspect of screenwriting that you
emphasize more than anything else such
as character plot you know writing every
day reading every day is there something
that's your mantra the answer is yes
there was something that I had with that
I emphasize every day and it is story
it's all about story story is everything
else we were talking earlier a moment
ago about dialogue I also says something
about character well what is dial and
what is character it it's you know the
the stuff that the protagonist or the
other characters in the in the movie
speak and it's what they do and what
they say it's this it's the story the
the richest the densest the most
analyzed and and studied character and
all of certainly english-language
dramatic literature and arguably world
dramatic literature is Hamlet certainly
he's a candidate for the number one
studied character was he crazy or does
he feign madness as part of his scheme
to bring justice to his late father and
and his father's memory there are so
many questions that are asked about
Hamlet so many books written about his
character what is the playwrights
description of Hamlet in the play it's
three words Prince of Denmark that's all
Shakespeare tells us about Hamlet so
where does there's nothing about
melancholy for example not in the
description of the character nor
anywhere in the play does that word
appears so where does this Hamlet guy
come from the answer is what he does and
what he says that's what makes up a
character and again to create a
character like that takes a bunch of
time because it's a story it's really
part of the story these things don't
break apart into separate discrete
entities but rather have functions
together only when they are linked as
functions of one another
you